your organization actually channels
millions of dollars to various things
and people actually wanted to like bear
fruit and bear results
um and one of the frustrations so many
Americans have right now is uh hey send
money and then the problem doesn't get
any better and then they're like oh you
know the problem is not enough money
send more money and then you're like uh
you know I'm not quite sure that's
actually gonna do it and I'm going to
use an example that you know that just
that I happen to know the numbers on
um so let's say that your New York City
Schools uh and you're spending thirty
three thousand dollars per student per
year
um on on your school system and the
results aren't good and then people look
at it and be like wait a minute there
are 30 kids in a classroom it's a
million bucks like how is the teacher
getting paid like you know they're not
getting paid uh you know half a million
or a quarter million so you're looking
around being like what's going on and
then when someone says it's like you
know the problem like system needs more
money and then you're like wait a minute
I'm not sure
in my experience and and I I think
you'll agree with this but tell me that
the issue is is rarely money and it's
rarely ideas because money is there if
you if you have the political will to
get it and ideas are plentiful ideas
frankly are cheap it's it's it's
executional capacity right and and doing
and aligning incentives and when we
don't have the capacity to execute on
the dollars or incentives are perverted
which is kind of gets again back to to
the basis of what we're trying to do
with forward then you're not going to
get you're not going to get good or
efficient results and so we spend a lot
of time kind of focusing on the money I
think because it's an easy or sexy ask
but thinking about
um incentives and implementation and
maintenance is not nearly as sexy and
it's much more kind of Technical and
pedantic but you know without that type
of approach we're not going to get good
results in our public education we're
not going to get good results in our
infrastructure you know or in our
political systems oh yeah you and I are
trying to solve the root structural
problems and create value I mean you're
an entrepreneur you know you you build
things uh like I consider myself the
same and so you naturally are like okay
like let's see what kind of problems we
can solve and there you know there's no
shortage of them
um I mean you've done so in a way that's
influenced uh you know at this point
probably like tens of thousands or even
hundreds of thousands of lives
in New Orleans and Beyond like in in the
region uh you know I I have been trying
to do the same since I started adventure
for America in 2011 so I guess I've been
at it for 12 years and it it led me into
the political realm because I started to
realize that number one the biggest
problems we have are unsolvable without
a functioning government
you know what I mean I mean like that
there's like a whole series of problems
we can solve with with commercial uh
applications and and companies that are
going to make money but then there's
this whole Suite of things that you kind
of need the government to have it
together
you kind of you kind of need government
to fix immigration right yeah that's a
fine example you know let's let's make a
short list just for fun I'm gonna say
you need government on immigration
AI climate change infrastructure
education
homelessness uh infrastructure you know
I'm up to seven or so and let me
actually give you another one which I
think is is is a little bit more
ephemeral but I think is incredibly
important and that is uh national
identity and Trust in institutions
because without that we get kind of back
to a hobbsian jungle pretty quickly
right and so you can't no wonder you
listen to that Peter turchin interview
Michael because he's like oh we're
like approaching Hobson jungle territory
coming around the curve yeah so I think
that's why the work of forward and
everybody who's involved in this space
um is so is so important because
everything points to us going through a
period that's going to be politically
and technologically disruptive I mean
that that's that's a fact right and so
the question is if we're going to come
out the other side with a country that
we are proud of and where our kids and
grandkids can stay then I think there's
an imperative on those of us that are
lucky enough to have the ability to do
something to do it otherwise it's a
decade from now and you know uh and you
know we might not I might be in Denmark
you might be in Belize and I think
there's going to be a lot of sense of
regret because America is a young
country
um it's it's still an experiment and
it's it needs to still have people who
are interested in propelling it and
evolving it forward in a in a better way
um I want to dig into something you said
half jokingly at the top where you you
referenced um working in a restaurant
which I totally agree with and my first
job was working as a busboy in a Chinese
restaurant uh and people were taken
aback by my perfect English because most
of the employees at that restaurant you
know we're getting busted from Chinatown
where are you from
well you know I mean I went to school
with their kids because it was my
hometown uh and um so a couple of busboy
stories randomly so number one I was a
busboy because my written Chinese wasn't
good enough to translate orders to the
kitchen which they needed in written
Chinese so it's like well I can't take
orders so I guess you're busing uh
number two everyone else would get a bus
from New York City's Chinatown to the
restaurant and then leave at the end of
the night
um and then I would get in my my you
know parents Honda Accord and just drive
home drive home individually be like
yeah bye everybody
um the three is that we would eat
uh leftovers from the the night
um like as a late night dinner
um sometimes that food was not great
because it was frankly the food that
didn't make that table uh and so I so my
my go-to was white rice with hot with
doused and hot and sour soup with uh the
fried noodles on top
hey you you were young and you're living
your best life yeah there were good
times so you definitely do learn about
service and people and money and just
the basics okay can I can I tell you the
most important lesson that I learned
about that from that which which really
saves my hide on a daily basis here it's
true story so our first chef was it was
a guy from Marseille and he was a very
talented chef but he smoked he chained
smoked Marlboro Red so he'd killed his
taste buds and um but he was you know he
was kind of a Marseille kind of you know
you know Saj poet De La Roux anyway
there's this one night and a woman gets
the boulia base and she calls me over
and she says um I don't like my bully a
base right and so you know I said right
on all right well you know I'm I'm gonna
I just I copper the whole meal it costs
us whatever it costs us and you know and
they walk out and and you know and they
proceed to go and and just tear us apart
on Yelp or whatever people were on you
know back then Zagats or whatever
and so you know then the same kind of
thing happened a few a few weeks later
and just for some reason instead of just
comping the meal I went and I sat down
with her and I said
um you know I'm really sorry about your
bouillabase and I said it with a
straight face
um in.com San Francisco I said but you
know tell me what's wrong with it tell
me what you don't like about it so I can
get some feedback back to the kitchen
and we'll try to do better next time and
she proceeded to talk about how there
wasn't enough broth and you know and the
shellfish were inadequate and the toast
was soggy and I gave her a glass of wine
and she proceeded actually after that
became one of our best customers and
what I took from that is that people
want to have their problem acknowledged
and to be heard far more than they want
that problem to actually be solved so
the worst thing that you can do is to
ignore somebody when they're expressing
uh distress about something
um but if you go and say tell me about
your problem
you've then succeeded because you've
heard them and if you if you solve the
problem that's lanyap then you're truly
a hero but so now in this job when we
get hit by stuff every day my action
almost every time is to go right to the
source of the problem and say you know
I'm sorry tell me what's going on and
it's just that that is a restaurant
lesson that that I learned um by copying
a lot of meals
hey YouTube glad you're enjoying the
podcast if you really like it hit
subscribe and then YouTube will notify
you every time we have a bang up new
guest thank you